it's a very important film to all of us
to see a woman a black woman in this
this sort of comedy you know it's very
Sandra Bullock is a very pretty woman
what Julie Robert you know I don't think
we've really seen a black woman like
this in a comedy yeah yeah like this you
know are we rolling
no well now we can go oh well listen yes
congratulations on this and thank you um
seeing this movie it's great to see you
in this role because it feels like it's
earned not that it has to be earned but
you know you've worked so hard and
worked so consistently so seeing you in
this kind of character and seeing the
fact that you said you wanted to play
this kind of character for so long like
what's that gratification like for you
now we'll see after it opens no for me I
mean I've always that's that's where I
grew up loving comedy um I moved to LA
thinking I was gonna book a sitcom and I
ended up booking dramatic series after
dramatic beats after dramatic role
dramatic films and finally you know I've
done comedy but to star in my own comedy
it's what I was always wanting and thank
God thank God for will Packer whoa and
Bryan Robbins cuz that's who actually
brought me the project I love it this
movie in principle is a flip on what
women want right but how is this movie a
movie for men and women I think this is
a movie for men and women because men
sometimes you know you need to be aware
of things you need to be things need to
be brought to your attention and
sometimes you know this is a man's world
and you know if you're so used to having
everything if you're used to that
privilege you don't know until someone
brings it to your attention so hopefully
that's what this film will do like women
we can talk about equal pay we can march
we can protest all we want but until we
have the powers to be across a table to
reach across the table to help us you
know so hopefully that's what men will
take away from this and
and not only that you know what as
executive producer I was very adamant
about making sure we take care of the
men don't mail bash because we want men
to come to this movie too and get the
lesson right so I love how we lifted we
shed light on the single father I think
we handle them with such great care I
thought so too yes yeah with Olli
specifically she was a very outspoken
this brash character were there any
people that you were looking to for
inspiration I thought there was elements
of like in a way a bit of a cardi B
aspect a bit of a Kanye aspect did you
look to other people for that no I
actually look to my agent Tracy Jacobs
who is a woman that sits on the board of
all men at UTA and I would talk to her a
lot she was like you have no idea how
much I identify with Ali her and then I
remember when I worked at the Pentagon
when I was in college there was a woman
who was a head of the office the
division I worked in and her name was
Henry Smith and Henry you know her name
is Henry you know I just thought she was
cool and a badass cuz all those men had
to come into the office and an answer to
her and I just thought she was amazing I
remember the power that she had and I
remember going to her as a young woman
trying to you know set up my future
because I had to pay for my college and
I went to her and I only in her office I
was working in the summer program so I
went to her and I said can I please I
heard that you did my research and I
knew the government had to stay in
school program so I went to her and I
was like I know you gotta say it's cold
her in my case I'm a saint I'm you know
I'm in school I'm trying to put myself
through school she made my position stay
in school pro I'm staying school so I
was able to continue working so I love
women of power you know so that I drew
from her in my agent amazing lastly I
know the saying before you've had so
much success lately and I feel like you
having this breakthrough the last couple
years along with someone like Tracee
Ellis Ross and Regina King right now in
Viola Davis black
coming up and being successful and kind
of breaking through in the mainstream
after working for so long it's something
you've noticed as well or is that kind
of just I've totally noticed it as a
matter of fact that's what I set out to
do because people say I started late
like I didn't get my first real big job
until 29 I was 29 so I was like but we
get to see these men going to hand these
productive careers after 40 how come not
women so that's been my mission my
entire career so I'm happy to see it and
I'm so happy for you again thank you